[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition de votre journal d'information
locale dernière édition pour cette
semaine et en ce 20 octobre nous allons
revenir sur les bons résultats et des
tricolores en cyclisme sur piste à
domicile au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les bleus
offrent un bien meilleur visage après
les mauvais résultats à rio cet été
le haut débit sur l'ensemble de la
commune de voisins-le-bretonneux c'est
pour demain une réunion d'information à
destination des habitants vient de se
tenir et puis le mondial de l'automobile
a connu une chute de fréquentation mais
les concessionnaires garde malgré tout
le moral les ventes se portent bien
c'est ce que nous verrons à la fin de ce
journal les championnats d'europe de
cyclisme sur piste ont donc débuté ce
mercredi au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la france en
opération reconquête après le fiasco des
jeux olympiques de rio l'été dernier a
débuté cette première journée par deux
médailles laurie berton a obtenu la
médaille de bronze sur l'épreuve est de
l'élimination un peu plus tôt dans la
soirée le sprinteur quentin lafargue à
lui raflé la médaille d'or sur le km en
devançant de deux dixièmes seulement
l'allemand eric angleur le sportif qui
habite saint quentin en yvelines était
au micro de notre journaliste sportif
michael et demi d'eau c'est très
important one très important et
et voilà je suis très très très contente
pour le par rapport au travail que j'ai
pu faire je suis un coéquipier qui se
font dans une équipe de france qui est
en train de recréer et
suis du coup bas j'étais plus jeune
l'année dernière j'ai un des plus denses
un scanner et ben voila j'ai un petit
peu d'expérience mais
je me propose pas en leader je prépare
mes objectifs et j'essaie d'être le plus
performant possible quentin lafargue
vous l'avez vu 25 ans est le nouveau
leader de cette nouvelle génération
française le sprinteur saint quentinois
accompagné des cyclistes d'endurance
dans ces jeunes pousses on retrouve
florian maître sébastien vigier ou
encore le trappistes baja main thomas
tous les trois sont âgés de 19 à 21 noms
on écoute la réaction de vincent jacquey
sur cette délégation plutôt jeune c'est
un bel avantage puisque ça veut dire
qu'on a de la réserve ça veut dire que
derrière on a toute une génération qu'on
souhaite accompagner à grandir et
derrière petit à petit la guérir assez
assez grande compétition internationale
a les championnats d'europe qui se
poursuivre jusqu'à dimanche au vélodrome
national à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
nous y reviendrons bien sûr au cours de
nos prochaines éditions et puisque l on
parle de cyclisme c'est aujourd'hui en
fin de journée qu'a été inaugurée est la
rue laurent fignon à montigny le
bretonneux une rue qui mène bien
évidemment vélodrome à la plaque portant
le nom du vainqueur du tour de france 83
84 est décédé en 2010 a été dévoilée par
son épouse et par thierry braillard le
secrétaire d'état aux sports les images
les réactions ce sera lundi dans ce
journal nous restons à montigny le
bretonneux avec le réaménagement de
l'avenue cheikh est celle qui a été
lancé fin septembre ce sont des travaux
qui doivent permettre de rénover les
trottoirs les zones de stationnement les
emplacements également pour les arbres
tous les détails avec nicolas d'andry
l'avenue joseph kessel à montigny le
bretonneux se refait une beauté les
travaux ont débuté le 27 septembre ce
chantier découpé en trois phases va
s'étaler sur trois ans la première phase
par de l'avenue nicolas bour et va
jusqu'à la rue de chambéry on réalise
l'état les stationnements réduit les
frottements aux normes pmr l'éclairage
public ont mis à neuf avec de
l'éclairage led et puis dépose les poses
de la végétation coût total du
réaménagement autour de 3 millions
d'euros pour saint quentin en yvelines
et environ 100000 euros pris en charge
par montigny le bretonneux
objectif de ce projet rénover les
infrastructures urbaines sécuriser la
mobilité des piétons et assurer la
survie des arbres chatons des trottoirs
qui avait plus de 30 ans qui ont été le
béton est déformé à plusieurs
endroits par les racines l'épousé
rationnaires des armes la première phase
des travaux doit être bouclé avant les
fêtes de fin d'année
pourquoi la verrière et elle contrainte
de se tourner vers l'état pour être sûr
que son écoquartier aboutisse c'est
ainsi que débute le courrier reçu depuis
quelques jours par les habitants de la
commune un courrier qui reprend
l'historique du dossier il y est
question des enjeux et surtout de ce
conflit avec l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines cette dernière
refusant pour l'instant de faire avancer
ce projet de plus de 72 hectares
comprenant 1800 logements
l'agglomération qui demande à revoir la
copie pour la verrière c'est un blocage
initié par le maire de la commune
voisine elancourt elle les instances du
gouvernement vont donc devoir se
prononcer est même si la maire de la
commune conclut elle la prise en main
par l'état peut être longue et complexe
l'arrivée de la fibre à voisins le
bretonneux se précisent les premiers
travaux débutent tout juste et puis une
réunion vient d'avoir lieu pour informer
les habitants qui pourrait en bénéficier
dès 2017 le reportage de mélanie poker
j'espère simplement qu'ils vont aller
très vite parce que on attend avec
impatience d'avoir un peu plus de débit
on a un des pics très médiocre depuis
des années et on aurait bien voulu avoir
qu'un seul et même opérateur et avoir la
fibre quoi rapidement très mauvais des
bleus est très très mauvais et surtout
très intermittent avec d une qualité
très variable service qui est d'assez
mauvaise qualité voilà le mauvais débit
à voisin un problème récurrent qui
devrait bientôt changer d'ici mars 2010
est les premiers habitants pourront
bénéficier de la fibre nous avons
installé concrètement les armoires de
mutualisation qui est un petit peu le
socle de
du déploiement du ftth sur voisins le
bretonneux donc de la fibre optique
alors le premier lot qui est fait sur
2016 et qui s'étalera un peu sur 2017
correspond à peu près à 2000 logements
sur voisin le très haut débit permettra
aux vies si noah de recevoir des données
numériques plus rapidement l'arrivée de
la fibre a été annoncée par la commune
en janvier de cette année lorsqu'on a on
a appris que peut-être il y avait une
possibilité pour l'arcep de lever le
lever le monopole de sfr et numericable
nous sommes engouffrés dans la brèche
pour écrire et demander effectivement
est-ce que orange puisse postuler aussi
à voisins c'est orange c'est le budget
d'orange voilà après ils vont donner
d'explications effectivement ce soir sur
comment après les particuliers peuvent
se raccorder et choisir l'opérateur
qu'il souhaite évidemment mais ça ne
représente aucun budget pour la commune
une fois toutes les installations
réalisées plus de 4000 foyers seront
connectés la totalité de la commune
devrait être entièrement fibré d'ici
direction coignières à présent où s'est
tenu le traditionnel banquet des anciens
chaque année la municipalité propose ce
moment festif aux habitants entre repas
jeux et concert d'accordéon 250
personnes étaient présentes thème retenu
la chasse pour le maire il était
important de rendre cet hommage à celles
et ceux qui font notamment vivre les
associations
c'est convivial on est bien reçu
et c'est parfait entre repas on danse
bon on a des jeux on participe à
beaucoup de choses des fois on peut
chanter ça dépend si la possibilité mais
chez nous ça se passe bien le but c'est
la convivialité que en fin de compte la
maman aussi privilégié pour nous élus de
rencontrer nos aînés s'est pas toujours
le cas et c'est vraiment ce moment
privilégié qu'on
espère y perdurer dans le temps et on
fait tout pour cela hier mercredi
jacques attali était invité à participer
à une conférence sur le campus i
yvelinois d' hec l'ancien conseiller
spécial de françois mitterrand a
notamment évoqué l sa vision pour la
france il a donné son point de vue sur
les enjeux de 2010 est nicolas
kirillovitch étaient présents
priorité à l'éducation à l'europe ou à
la lutte contre les inégalités jacques
attali est une vision précise du monde
et de la france une vision qu'il a
exposée durant plus d'une heure devant
un amphithéâtre plein l'économiste et
écrivain consulté par tous les
présidents de la république est revenu
notamment sur la prochaine campagne
présidentielle avec ironie leur combat
l'europe
la laïcité comment
la formation des chômeurs je n'ai pas
cité sac est pour moi absolument majeur
la formation des chômeurs c'est la clé
donc on ne parle pas de leur sujet et
donc forcément le prochain président de
comme les trois précédentes chirac
monsieur sarkozy est sûre l'homme ont
été élus avec un mandat explicite ne
rien faire
et ils ont parfaitement
le fondateur de l'organisation
humanitaire action contre la faim a
surtout exposé sa vision pour le long
terme lui qui estime que la france peut
être la grande puissance du 21e siècle
un propos convaincants pour ses
auditeurs d'un soir
je pense que c'était un débat oui très
fait et qui nous aiderait je pense que
les étudiants h essais à aborder
l'avenir avec un certain temps ce qui
m'a marqué c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
une entreprise que me berk on voit
qu'avec un peu un poussin et on a un
sens que ça va devenir un truc énorme
dit qu'en fait ça va tout va tellement
vite que c'est déjà en train de en train
de disparaître et jacques attali risque
d'être une nouvelle fois convoité à
l'approché des présidentielles lui qui
ne se reconnaît pour le moment dans
aucun candidat
tout autre sujet à présent le salon de
l'automobile a refermé ses portes
dimanche dernier le 16 octobre une
édition 2016 qui restera marqué par une
baisse de la fréquentation et pourtant
les concessionnaires automobiles locaux
ont bénéficié de cet événement pour
vendre des véhicules il propose
également des nouveaux services tournés
vers le numérique nous nous sommes
rendus dans une concession rénové qui
vient tout juste d réouvrir ses portes
le reportage de patrick jacques de
dixmude et de nicolas landry
14% c'est la baisse de fréquentation du
salon de l'automobile de paris par
rapport à 2014 mais du côté des
concessionnaires locaux le mondial de
l'auto offre des opportunités
c'est le cas du groupe courtois à
montigny le bretonneux qui organisait
des portes ouvertes le week end dernier
on a battu le record 1 ce week-end de
vente on a vendu sur ce site plus de 30
véhicules et fait plus de 100 essais
tous modèles confondus ces chiffres
s'expliquent par une organisation
spécifique lors du mondial de
l'automobile de paris en fait on est en
interconnecté avec les équipes du salon
les clients vont voir vont voir la gamme
vont découvrir deux mots de nouveaux
modèles éventuellement ils vont voir des
modèles plus existants il ya des
conditions spécifiques au salon et nous
ensuite on est mis en relation via via
internet on a des positions d'achat ou
décès et on a su ensuite le travail en
concession de proximité pour faire
essayer la gamme aller plus loin dans la
dans l'explication des différents
modèles et après on peut leur faire
bénéficier le cas échéant de conditions
spécifiques ou de destination de leurs
véhicules pour les reprendre après un an
de travaux cette concession vient de
réouvrir ses portes une rénovation pour
digitaliser certaines activités offertes
par la structure objectif proposer une
montée en gamme du service rendu au
client à aucune mise en main ce qu'on
appelait la découverte du véhicule
prenait un quart d'heure vingt minutes
aujourd'hui on est plutôt sur des
schémas de plusieurs fois une heure on
fait une première une première
explication première mise en main on a
après des casque virtuel qui permet de
faire découvrir tout ce qui est aidé à
la conduite c'est comme dans
l'informatique il faut plusieurs
plusieurs fois pour bien maîtriser
l'outil donc on doit obligés d'avoir des
commerciaux de très haut niveau ce que
ce que l'on a et on les forme énormément
ça internet permet aux clients de
choisir son véhicule sur le web
face à ces différentes évolutions et à
la concurrence le métier de
concessionnaire temps à s'adapter à ces
défis du 21e siècle
c'est la fin de cette édition le journal
revient lundi aux horaires habituels dès
demain vendredi vous avez rendez vous
avec nikola kirillovitch pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'hebdo
[Musique]